oh you know it's worth more than 30 days
already in what we are seeing right now
as i'm talking to you there was a very
very big bomb falling on the some one of
the districts of kiev right now the
capital is standing strong but we are
seeing that russians as usual lying to
us that they will
they take their troops somewhere else
yeah dennis we saw those peace talks end
early in the week in turkey and out of
that came a promise if you like from the
russians to scale back military action
around chenehive and where you are the
capital kiev and your president said as
much as you did you know we'll look at
russians actions not their words from
what you're experiencing have the
russians gone anyway in scaling back
their attack on the capital
you know uh there is a lie a big lie and
only after this coming what our russian
officials are saying because we do
already see that the number we have
so-called peace talks russians start to
bombard the capital and other cities
even harder so the russians they don't
just understand that they are losing
this war and we are making them lose
this war we do hope that of course the
war will end in the coming weeks or
months but we see that you know we need
to the support from the west to make
sure that we press in russia very hard
and we have been hearing from ukrainian
military sources that russian troops are
perhaps scaling back on
troops on the ground near the capital
but concentrating on long-range attacks
and we're also hearing from
the head of the gchq
today who said that russian troops are
low in morale and low in organization
they're
really disorganized have you encountered
russia's troops where you are and what
can you make of what's happening amongst
their ranks
you know i'm talking a lot to our army
guys and they're telling us that this is
all true the russian troops what they're
doing they're doing just a lot of silly
mistakes and we are reading them on
tactics what we are seeing is that the
only morale they have is to steal things
from
our flats they come into our flesh they
beat our people they rape our women and
of course you've probably heard the
story published by times that no this is
happening everywhere what they are doing
is just inhuman they're proving
themselves to be barbaric so this is
their only motivation because they're
poor in their country and they try to
earn some money here
yeah you mentioned some of the
atrocities there the head of gchq did
say that he felt putin was being forced
to adopt plan b which he described as
barbarity against civilians and cities
anecdotally what have you been hearing
from those who have encountered russian
troops
no you know these are the stories that
no one wants to hear but they are true
because like they're taking 16 17 year
old girls
raping them and after that they kill
them
they come to the places of the people of
old crineis and they just told give us
some food or we will kill you you know i
don't know even if nazis have performed
something like this back in world war ii
because
what they're showing
you know they come as they're telling us
of course to save us from someone from
nationalists but
at the same time they prove themselves
that they are the most inhuman army in
the world right now
we've heard so much about the resilience
of the ukrainian people
and again that was mentioned in that
speech by the head of gchq that vladimir
putin did not expect the resistance he
has encountered in ukraine
and i want to talk about something
president zielenski said after those
peace talks and it was about concessions
on both sides he treated you know
russian concessions with skepticism but
there was a lot of talk about ukraine
becoming a neutral country giving up its
idea of nato membership and he said that
they he would put that to the people it
would you know go to a referendum what
would ukrainian people accept to bring
this war to an end in your mind
so you know the last these talks and
what ukrainian side proposed to russians
it was totally accepted by ukrainian
community and what i'm seeing and
reading from the experts we don't
understand the reality that we need to
at least put russian troops to where
they were as of 23rd of february we do
need to continue talks on diplomatic
backing crimea and donbass to ukraine
not with war solutions
and of course the referendum is only
possible if there is no war on the
territory of ukraine but still we don't
understand that no one will give up our
sovereignty we do not give up our
territories and we trust our president
so much and we hope that they will
achieve whatever we can but as i'm
telling to you
to put him to date mentioned to the
private italian prime minister that he
will not accept these terms and he do
not see any points of the discoloration
of the conflict so you see that the
problem it lies in kremlin
there's ganza um ukrainian youth
delegate to the un thank you so much for
speaking to us from the ukrainian
capital kiev we hope that you stay safe
and thank you for taking the time today
we appreciate it
thank you